every ending is a new beginning another
great Gina linetti entrance you better
savor these while you still can Sarge
Gina I am not in the mood
how are you so unaffected by all this
because I have already moved on I'm
devoting my energy to my new project
Gina's on
it's a one-stop online portal for my
legions of followers speaking of heel
what's up g hive it's Queen G I'm bored
at work so I'm gonna prank all my
coworkers that sounds like a bad idea
for an already crappy day fine Sarge I
won't do it
I will do it so you can count this as my
first prank I guess unofficially what's
this looks like a red wire oh that
wasn't here before what's a computer do
I mean computers have wires tears
doesn't doesn't it know it's going in a
different direction than the other wires
trying to really busy I can't talk about
this anymore
I got 500 feet of red wire at a flea
market by Del Mar high school 20 bucks
for the whole spool crazy
what a deal oh they'll be fine
I made it up there hey I know what would
cheer you up let's go wait outside the
bathroom for Tom and scare him that
would cheer me up okay ready and God
rose Oh Jerry
guys oh good well I think you might be
having a heart attack
what are you serious oh so much stuff is
happening right now call 9-1-1 okay just
breathe okay you're gonna be fine
Nora she's in a dinosaur dysphoric Jerry
get a grip sorry guys apology not
accepted
stop talking [ __ ] I wish I could stop
smelling dude seriously Jerry did you
eat farts for lunch
Tom yeah he's having a heart attack oh
no I know that Jerry you okay hey can I
talk to the captain
uh he's on the phone do you want a
coffee while you wait they made me an
extra line on accident oh sure thank you
oh my god what is that man you just
drank some man guys check back in to see
if she dies well you're not really gonna
die probably okay just a little honey
for the G hive also you can talk to hold
he is not on the phone what is happening
it's a little something Michael do
pranks for the present one
Santiago I'm on the phone excuse me how
long is the wait for a table for two I
would never ever serve you not in a
million billion years it's a nice tux I
know it belonged to my grandfather he
was buried in it so family heirloom
so what's the deal we got to pay for our
own drinks that's what come on it'll be
fun and besides I'm a roulette expert
impossible
that is not a game of skill it is a game
of chance I could always kind of win it
roulette
oh really mm-hmm yeah how would you do
that my control you can't be serious
hey serious ever since I was a little
kid like eight or nine I could sort of
control things with my mind I don't
believe you would continue it was just
little things you know like I could make
something shake or I could make a marble
fall off the counter you know just
little things that's ridiculous you know
what uh why don't you move that cup rack
excuse me everyone attention in the
office please
Jim is about to prove his telekinetic
powers and he needs absolute silence go
ahead okay I'll try
hey Jim what's up buddy this is not
funny why is my stuff in here wow that's
weird
ooh daughter first a boy that's pretty
good yeah well I'm not paying for my own
stuff okay I know you did this because
you're friends with the vending machine
guy Oh Steve yeah oh no no no that's my
pencil cup I think so
and you're gonna hand it over to me I
love these Oh Ernest J one
and probably shoulda said no to some of
his ideas but he's on his way here right
now here he is just be cool
hey guys what's up oh I just remembered
can I show you something out to the
front area and leave your cellphone's
because if no reason just leave anything
they can't get wet actually like you
would normally okay here we go to the
parking lot now wow this is really sad
yep follow to me guys just go into the
parking lot for normal government
reasons sir he can't go through with
this I was gonna pull a prank no yeah
I've hired these guys in ski masks to
kidnap us and I was gonna pretend to be
a hero they were gonna shoot me and
drive the van into the river and that's
when the divers would go in pull you
guys out of the water and I would be
standing on the shore like hey you get
pranked much what's up we got these
squids from a special effects guy and I
was gonna say this code word that's what
I would push this button oh my god you
got blood all over me thank you I mean
it Ben that was amazing really best
prank ever Sarge I got a case for you
guy that's phone stolen at a bar last
night all right it's not that big a deal
I just need to file a police report for
my insurance company no it is a major
injustice and we're gonna set it right
there's a crappy old phone I'd rather
just get a new one but would believe
that we're here to help you shut your
damn mouth
nobody look like I only saw his back had
a blue hoodie on you just drank cement
you just drank cement where is my desk
that is weird
this is not funny this is totally
unprofessional okay well you're the one
who lost the desk I didn't lose my desk
okay calm down where was the last place
you saw okay who moved my desk I think
you should retrace your steps okay I am
going to tell Michael and this entire
office will be punished colder
warmer a little warmer Hey ooh
warmer warmer warmer warmer warmer cold
cold cold back up warmer hot red hot
very hot Dwight Schrute hi Dwight
um what sort of discounts are we giving
on the Jim I've given you this
information like 20 times it's by the
Rheem buildings now 978 sorry it's in
just k7 okay thank you gotta get back to
work
wash your hands Kevin separation
oh oh girl you look so sad you know it
would cheer you up nice bowl of miso
soup
no thanks Gina I'm not in the mood so
Gina is that soup up for grabs
Scully no my followers are sick of
watching you eat cement
[Music]
you